haha you're rid of us engine well we're
back after God so many years you too of
not aged well
aged spectacularly so ah
actually all I see in comments is like
you know so Jason's 15 14 so anywho this
is ocarina we're gonna do a couple of
these the next five I think yeah we got
yeah so the next five they're up and you
know what you're sort of do that like
every couple of weeks we'll just get
together and do a few more and go from
there
this episode um Jake's kids are growing
up but they grow up so fast
and a little too fast cuz one wants to
take over Jake's house effect he buys it
from Marceline for what was that gold
trade no no no no the base so ludicrous
base was that it something like that it
was awesome whatever one before I it was
a four necked base yeah I don't even
play guitar and I'm like I want that is
just absurd because of the how thick
that like oh my god that has that's
absurd and she was something I notice in
that scene did you notice that even
though he was in like a flashback she
was still covered up like with the hat
and gloves and everything's of the Sun
doesn't burn her and I know it's not a
flashback I think you teleported her
there okay get her back
oh okay maybe then she was just prepare
like oh just in case that happened yes
possible so whatever reason I just
thought was - she was still prepared for
the day yeah so he buys the house and is
trying to kind of teach Jake
responsibility because he seen him twice
in his entire life and but in this time
span this could be like under a year for
all he know because they do grow up so
quick like he even has his own wife and
kid now this does and he tells him you
gotta move out you gotta get your own
job and stuff but then Jake he makes a
little ocarina that doesn't work but he
made it be and he's giving his fatherly
advicing I love you I love you I love
you over and over which made me pee
myself I love my dog
let's go I love you I love you I love
you I love you I love you I love you I
love you I love you something about the
way Jake did it was just a little dance
going on yes and I'm sure he was and the
son says oh well I was hoping you learn
responsibility by getting a job and
moving out but you know maybe he's okay
and it ends there pretty much um so you
know the funny thing it took me a while
to realize what they were doing it
really was not until that ending right
with Oh done I always see what they're
doing like you know the kid that has to
grow up and instead it's the adult yeah
and take the responsibility and
everything um I liked it I the design of
the kids and the personalities that gave
them pretty quickly and pretty I don't
know I felt like I could just look them
and like identify what the
characteristics are what they're like
and so on and I really liked that I
thought that was really clever we saw a
little bit of the one that was one of
the computer one to stay at home wonder
whatever yeah we saw a little bit him
before of course we saw the
weird-looking daughter before but yeah
we have really seen the other ones and I
just love the way their design and look
I just think they are um and ya know it
was so fun it was it was creative the
two other little details I thought were
kind of clever was um I may not clever
but there's one part where when they
find the gold in the backyard is taken
away he shrinks down he's really tiny
inside the hole and and fin talks to
them and then you know he gives an idea
says you're right he gets big again I
thought to myself you know you didn't
have to animate that and that was like a
really interesting sort of 360 that they
you talk to it's like I just love that I
just love those little touches where
it's like they don't need to do that but
it's it's something Jake we're probably
doing that moment just like he's feeling
small so he literally goes mom um and
then the other thing I like is when they
see where he uh where the son live yeah
and they find out if he's really rich so
rich that even the backgrounds are
designed nicer like they're shaded nicer
and there's more there's like color line
work and a lot more detail yeah I would
say detail in more of the icy shading
because a lot of backgrounds are very
detailed but this was definitely shaded
to cel-shaded and it played with light
and so I guess I guess it's more like
things were clearer yes my Disney yeah
yeah like cuz they're walking and
there's the fairy and the fairy have
some extra lines and it seems to be more
like detail than that sense where
everything was a little bit more clear
and a little bit more crisp and a lot
more like and Jake even says it feels
like a fairy tale yeah I really thought
they were gonna do something like what
Disney may they'll do that next time I
don't know but yeah no I like that I was
that was a fun episode I liked it a lot
actually I thought it was really cool
especially in the end I love I love love
love the idea that you know everybody
whether we want it or not we have our
own idea of what's correct and what's
proper and what's the right way to be
and it's funny and it's silly because
look the kid is older than than the
father and blah blah blah but in the end
I loved how they left it where he does
say okay I think he's all right you're
the phone fail the time haha Galka says
well here go go ahead up so yeah keep
going
Jory keeps telling me about oh well yeah
so she was under something good there
too
hey was your boss calling Oh what boss
no no no but actually it did remind me
so we forgot to address her I forgot to
address I should say I really like kind
of common
they were doing where Jake's like let me
tell you how this all goes oh yeah I'm
and the tough guys just picking on the
little guys and then when they hit
everything the way they want it that's
when they made the laws that it's
totally unfair to the little guy just in
commentary yeah it actually kind of
makes sense because who makes the rules
whoever's in power yeah I'm usually
who's in power the strong person yeah
the survival the players yeah yeah so no
I feel I sir saw that I was like huh
this is kind of eerily for the human
race I suppose but no I thought that was
pretty clever even against our the the
an asian-style seemed a little different
there like just a touch I can't like
that there's something about this one
where like there's definitely a point
and a message and stuff but they still
allowed it to serve go sporadic and
certain areas a sort of trying new stuff
yeah I love it when they try as much as
we like to go on about like glitch is a
glitch or something like that like I do
like it when they try new stuff oh yeah
you know even just those subtle ways
like I said the backgrounds yeah we're
clear as I get closer to home I thought
that was really smart I liked what well
I like how they picked up with meat and
furniture furniture and meat yeah when
they give away the the money right they
gave away the money because they're like
we've never had to spend anything yet if
I'm only gonna have two and now they
need to and it's all gone
and he's like I got these two old
pictures they're interesting aren't they
and he just takes use like yeah I think
I went what cuz I always loved that
where where so it just goes I love that
I love how always like well you can stay
here on a ladder and they're actually
sleeping like pins gonna sleep up and
he's just like yeah hold on yeah I'm
fine I'm a tough kid
yeah and Jake just shrinks down to a
tiny little bed with himself on and then
someone steps on both of them then
they're in Jake or Finn goes to the
bathroom and the little goblin goes in
the corner on the phone oh my god he
said my apartment right now
I don't know it's men called cos man
wasn't in there for very long like he
must have called that a while ago
no he's in here now Emmy is like that
wasn't them like really yeah I loved
that that was fun and especially a lot I
liked it there wasn't like a recycling
of characters this time around a lot of
times it'll have like some characters
kind of show up like when people were
piling and I was expecting to kind of
see like maybe cinnamon bun or even tree
trunks or something like that but there
was like pretty much no regulars in this
episode yeah I mean even the kids have
kind of changed around ya know and I've
gotten older uh yeah I kind of like that
there's something it sounds weird it
could very well because we've been away
from it yeah well you know but there was
how they seemed to touch pressure about
this episode yeah I mean if that very
well could because like the story wise
there's nothing really that new except
the kids growing older yeah um but yeah
there is something to they just try like
even just the little touches it just
seems a little different and now I see
you brought back I brought the dog back
thinks the Doug okay well one other
thing I want to get your feedback on did
um did you feel the ending was a little
rushed okay it's obviously rushed but
does that distract you at arguer you
just can't seems about right
what do you mean with well with them
making amends and stuff I mean because
well the way I look at it I guess for me
is that that's jeg vil hmm and I think
his son realizes that that's at this
point I'm the best he's gonna get yeah
like he's made the efforts or a thing
the efforts there yes it's an ocarina
that has really no holes and it's not
Hollow so I mean and he realizes and
he's looking at it he's like you know
what it's there the efforts there he's
trying there's some connection and I
mean I think if they had Jake to like a
whole one eight-year-old like an entire
like 180 then a 360 and all that stuff
like
wouldn't be Jake hmm you know because
Jake is kind of a doofus kind of a
weirdo like remember him come flying in
for the birthday pardon he's like just
gonna say right now I forgot to eat
gifts but I brought dinner a little tiny
pile of Nick that's I did what you say
that's a lion consistent with him like
because he was really obsessed with his
kids for a while you know there's one
episode because by the end of the
episode they were already grown up and
ready to move out I guess that's true
yeah and he was depressed and everything
but I mean if you're a parent kind of
for a day and a half you're more a
babysitter than a parent you know what I
mean it's like being a parent for way
too many years you know so no long that
you think you have a watch when clearly
you right here see yeah um you can see
like oh you know your nanny or that
stuff yet he got together but in a sense
the end of the day you're the kids
you're taking care of go back to their
parent or whatever and Jake was a parent
for like a couple days and that's all it
was and yes he said I only saw you twice
so far you know and that kind of said
something that one day and then a little
bit later you know and I think the last
thing I think they talk about is the the
far the far away shot the long shot when
Oh goodbye and but because the SHA so
far away you literally can't hear them
say goodbye you can just ban I that was
pretty clever I get invited you haven't
seen her joke like that Adventure Time
before yeah it was really clever so yeah
no I thought that was because that first
I thought was an audio friend yeah and
then but they had the little birds still
tweeting hmm and I'm like oh that's not
an audio problem that's just the way
done okay it's just nice you like that
no I thought it was pretty funny you
coming back in and you've done
stupid real world real world stupid day
job well just pick up with your thought
like nothing ever happened
I'll edit it back in I'll be amazing
just get over me in my talking this oh
he does anyways yeah yeah however watch
them but ya know uh-oh I was saying that
I loved it because in me know in the end
I liked it because they did kind of
leave it with that it's okay I've we
don't all have to be the same Jake even
though Kim kil whan still doesn't
technically really approve of his
father's lifestyle innocence and if he
thinks you know things could be better
should be better at least in the end by
him saying you know I think he's okay
it's kind of an acknowledgement of all
right there's nothing wrong with him I
don't agree with it but there's nothing
wrong with it he'll be fine and I liked
it a little bit better because in the
beginning I honestly thought that it was
gonna be this big whole thing about he's
just doing this to be mean to his dad
because his dad never loved him that's
what I thought they were going to yeah
and and then Jake did that I love you I
love you I love you I love you I love
you you know and I was expecting this
big to-do about it and I really liked
that kind of subtle like okay you can
tell he appreciates that his dad and
maybe he is a stick-in-the-mud because
his dad wasn't around that much you know
or maybe it's Kim kil whan 'aa way of
rebelling
because kids typically don't want to be
like their parents so they typically you
have to repel them yeah there should not
be the exact opposite yeah interesting
sir a circle that develops there yeah so
they need to go right and I know I like
today I liked it a lot better than where
I thought it was originally gonna go and
I and it was it wasn't this big
production it was just a very simple
thing and you kind of sat there or I
kind of sat there and thought about it
and I was like yeah I know I like that
it wasn't you know the big speech and
the big well you know you see and I like
this wonder if Jake gets his bone back
the gigantic gold bone well I mean no no
no I choose to believe not I just would
love to see this episode redone back
when they had a full treasure room Oh
God
so he buys the property and he's like
okay let me see your truck crap other
like here take all our money we want our
house back you guys some legalese
together but you know think about it if
they had the old Treasury room they
would have been able to buy it back no
questions they probably be greedy back
that cuz I know we need this treasure
because they didn't realize they didn't
need it then no you can't have it it's
ours we found it we follow why I know
they're not they wouldn't use it for
what it's supposed to be
so either way yeah price don't wouldn't
turn out good bro I know what they got
the bone from what animal or creature no
they melted all that gold into a bone
shape no I'm imagining some gigantic
monster that has like a big old bony
rags or something yeah why don't you get
up and leave
fine I'll get up and leave I've never
got that left before I'm getting up and
leaving you my you there's a lot more
often than he claims I mean he's lying
really oh god oh god